do you remember when Dana White did this
uh like mini documentary when the whole
covert thing happened afterwards because
oh yeah he said he was because the way
the media was yeah they're saying making
like a bad guy and it's not so he's
planning on doing another one with why
people are talking smack on the UFC
power slap and he's gonna like you know
whatever I don't know man you have to be
that'd be cool man be cool
I don't need that dog
dude you're probably the best one the
supporter of I mean not supporter but
you're you gave it a chance like you're
like yeah like I'm watching it so
ridiculous but I don't see how it's even
allowed until I'm 23. yeah and he was
talking to Robbie Foxx your dude and he
just hates the media like the what like
I'm sure he's gonna have in there what
they did to Rogan and him and all this
[__] power slap lately he just won't
give it up that's a bad idea I get it
dude I fight dude I get a date I'm with
you bro Double Down